ahora que ya conocemos todas nuestras
reacciones veamos si podemos juntarlas
nuestro objetivo es formar esta molécula
a partir de benceno una técnica que
podemos usar es la retro síntesis pensar
en el mecanismo desde adelante hacia
atrás cuál sería el precursor inmediato
a esta molécula bueno necesitamos
analizar los grupos que están unidos a
nuestro anillo por ejemplo bromo sabemos
que el bromo es corto para dirigente
porque tiene pares de electrones libres
a su alrededor pero si observamos el
grupo nitro sabemos que es meta
dirigente porque tenemos una carga
formal positiva en el nitrógeno y por
aquí tenemos un grupo así lo que también
es un grupo meta dirigente
y este carbono en el carbón y lo es
parcialmente positivo entonces si
pensamos en cuál de estos grupos fue
agregado al último tiene sentido que
haya sido el bromo porque el bromo se
encuentra en posición meta respecto a
estos grupos
entonces dibujemos el precursor quitamos
el bromo y nos queda un grupo nitro y un
grupo así lo ahora cómo agregaríamos el
bromo a nuestro anillo bueno
necesitaríamos una reacción de broma
ción así que necesitamos bromo
y un catalizador como por ejemplo
bromuro de hierro efe de r3 muy bien
ahora que tendríamos que hacer para
formar esta molécula bueno tenemos un
grupo nitro y un grupo asilo así que
podríamos hacer una migración para
agregar el grupo nitro y una asimilación
de fred aircraft para agregar el grupo
asilo pero cuál de esas reacciones
ocurre primero resulta que no se puede
hacer una asimilación de freedom craft
si ya tenemos un grupo desactivan t en
el anillo eso significa que no podemos
poner primero el grupo nitro y después
el asilo sino más bien en este paso
agregaremos el grupo nitro
para el precursor inmediato de esto
quitamos el grupo nitro y nos queda un
grupo asilo para poder avanzar agregamos
claro ácido nítrico y ácido sulfúrico
concentrados
ahí está finalmente sólo necesitamos la
reacción de alquilación de freddo craft
y para saber qué tipo de cloruro de
asilo usaremos simplemente hay que
contar el número de carbonos aquí
tenemos 1 y 2 entonces necesitamos un
cloruro de asilo de 2 carbonos lo
dibujaré
y también necesitamos un catalizador
agreguemos cloruro de aluminio
nuestra síntesis está completa
empezaremos con una ágil acción de
freedom crafts y como el grupo así lo es
meta dirigente dirigirá al grupo nitro
hacia la posición meta finalmente
tenemos dos meta dirigentes que
dirigirán al bromo a su posición final
hagamos otro problema tenemos los mismos
grupos y la molécula se ve diferente
entonces haremos las mismas reacciones
que en la síntesis anterior pero lo
haremos en diferente orden nuevamente
analicemos los grupos
sabemos que el bromo es corto para
dirigente porque tiene pares de
electrones libres a su alrededor también
sabemos que el grupo nitro es meta
dirigente porque tiene una carga formal
positiva y nuestro grupo asilo también
es meta dirigente porque tiene
una carga parcial positiva en el carbono
del carbón y lo entonces qué reacción
ocurrió al último bueno tiene sentido
que haya sido la atracción porque el
grupo nitro se encuentra meta respecto
al grupo así lo el grupo así lo es meta
dirigente y el bromo más importante es
[ __ ] para dirigente por eso el grupo
nitro se encuentra en posición [ __ ]
respecto al bromo así que la última
reacción fue la administración dibujemos
el precursor
únicamente necesitamos quitar el grupo
nitro y nos queda nuestro anillo
por aquí el bromo
y por acá el grupo así lo muy bien y
como la última reacción fue ni tracción
necesitamos agregar ácido nítrico y
ácido sulfúrico concentrados muy bien
ahora pensemos en el precursor de esta
molécula nuevamente tenemos dos grupos
el bromo y el grupo asilo se encuentran
en posición para respecto al otro lo que
significa que el grupo corto para
dirigió al grupo asilo a la posición
para entonces ocurrió una asimilación de
freedom craft
eso significa que quitamos el grupo
asilo y sólo nos queda el bromo
este es el bromo benceno y como hacemos
una reacción de freedom craft
necesitamos un grupo así lo cloruro de
asilo de dos carbonos
nuevamente agregaríamos cloruro de
aluminio como catalizador
tal vez se estén preguntando por qué
hago una oscilación de fluido craps si
tenemos bromo que es un grupo desactivan
t bueno recuerden que el bromo es un
desactivan t débil no podríamos hacer
así la acción o alquilación si
tuviéramos un desactivan t fuerte pero
como este es un desactivan t débil
podemos obtener el producto para como el
producto en mayor cantidad y seguramente
también habrá un poco del producto [ __ ]
muy bien lo único que nos falta es pasar
de benceno a bromo benceno entonces
simplemente haríamos una broma ción
agregamos bromo y un catalizador hemos
completado la síntesis esta vez
empezamos con la reacción de formación
el bromo es corto para dirigente así que
pone el grupo asilo en la posición para
del producto mayor
después claro long y tramos como tenemos
un norte para dirigente y un meta
dirigente
el grupo nitro termina en esta posición
hemos terminado así es cómo podemos
resolver estos problemas de síntesis
usando la retro síntesis retrocedemos
paso a paso pensando en la molécula que
queremos obtener haremos otros dos
ejercicios en el siguiente vídeo que
quizá serán un poco más difíciles